we are so happy to be here and gail it
is your story take it away okay next up
we got an issue that an overwhelming
majority of couples say causes fights in
their relationship
apartment therapy reports a survey found
that 75 of couples argue over the
thermostat the survey said most people
said 70 degrees was the ideal setting
while men were more likely to pick lower
temperatures like 68 degrees okay so
let's do a thing around the table mm-hmm
what is your bird
yes oh i run really hot so at night i
want the room freezing my wife she wants
it warm so in order to compromise i get
to lower the temperature she gets to
snuggle up so we both win
so my fiance wellington if you could
would sleep in one of those things you
cook a hot pocket in in the microwave
you know he likes to be really
and i sleep like angelina jolie in a
ball gown with one leg out you know
i so i i have the window open i do i do
about 66 and wellington would do about
89.
well i don't have to worry about what
anyone's doing because i wake up with a
pile of animals on my bed and i like it
at about a 72. oh that's so weird mine
is 72 too gay it is i don't have anybody
but me myself and i and all three of us
like 72.
we have discovery
we like seven degrees uh my wife and i
both like it very cold but nobody in our
house gets to choose except for the baby
ah and the baby likes 68 but the babies
it's good for the babies no for the
family
we don't want to hear a peep from that
baby from the time you put the baby down
until 7am the next morning
sleep training days uh i miss them all
right next up technology is changing how
we live our lives but we all have those
old-fashioned things that we want to
hold on to well that's the subject of a
new book that i just read about in
people it's called 100 things we lost to
the internet
and it's a hundred short essays by
pamela paul of the new york times she
covers the loss of things like
mixtapes
cursive
and uh wall phones in the kitchen which
i love a wall phone and i i won't give
it up but do you have a landline
here's what really ticks me off
my landline is connected to my cable
so when the power goes out i lose my
landline and i just want to say
don't you dare touch my landline
what's one thing you miss from the end
honestly what i miss is boredom and i i
worry i have a 12 year old as well i
have nine year old too and i worry that
unlike me they will spend zero days of
their life just sitting on the porch
throwing rocks at nothing just thinking
thoughts uh boredom
died when the iphone was invented right
gail what's one thing you must photo
albums because everything's on your
phone yeah back in the day you take a
picture go and get it developed and put
it in a frame so i miss having that yes
nate what do you miss i missed the very
delightful yet stressful adventure
to go rent a vhs tape
you guys remember that yeah
but then you got you got to be kind
please rewind
[Applause]
we're going to go to our affiliates
across the u.s for some special news
updates and right now we want to check
in with susannah marquez at our cbs 2
affiliate in los
angeles hi suzanne
hi susan hi
drew ross gail tony and nate's great to
see you guys now when you think of
weddings taco bell may not be what
normally pops into your mind but talk
about cantina in pacifica northern
california might be the perfect wedding
spot it's on the beach it's gorgeous it
overlooks the water and serves wine and
beer and liquor versions of their
classic freezes and two high school
college sweethearts just tied the knot
there so what do you think is it a do
especially for i do's ross since you're
engaged
how about you uh okay i'm happy for this
couple good for them you know i'm
i really am i just want to say
personally i'm looking for wedding bells
not wedding bell grandes
i mean good for them i hope they
splurged and got taco supremes you know
we already know you you have champagne
tastes but what would you do for my
wedding i don't want to do taco bell for
the wedding i like it i like it and i
like being on the beach but i'm glad
that it works for them that's what i
think is the most important thing it
works
the average american wedding is like
what twenty five thousand it's out
thirty thousand dollars these days yeah
take that savings from the taco bell
wedding go on a honeymoon
college account buy a house
[Applause]
it's not about the actual wedding it's
it's how you describe it to people who
ask about it you say you know what we
had a beautiful wedding on the beach
you make a lot of sense you've all
convinced me
gorditas at my wedding
pretty good
that's a great story and we super
appreciate it
and i just want to thank tony and nate
and rossi the most handsome gentleman in
the news game
for being at this desk today and gail i
was wondering if you and i could have a
little girl party and discuss your
favorite things favorite things that you
created for everyone this year
[Applause]
[Music]
you